how much propaganda is there in the
world today in russia in ukraine in the
west
it's extraordinary
in russia of course it's total
ukraine is a different story they're at
war
expect propaganda
in the west
well let me quote
graham fuller
very highly placed in u.s intelligence
one of the top officials for
decades
dealing mostly with russia and
central asia
he recently said that in all the years
of the cold war
he's never seen any
extreme
rustophobrious russiaphobia
to the extent that he sees today
that's pretty accurate
i mean the u.s says
even
canceled
the
russian outlets
which means if you want to
find out what
sierra lover of
other russian officials are saying
you can't look it up on their own
outlets you have to
go through
all jazeera
indian
state television or some place where
they still
allow
russian positions to be expressed
and of course the propaganda is just
outlandish i think fuller is
quite correct on this
and russia of course you expected
total propaganda there's nothing
any uh independent outlets
such as there were have been crushed
if the media is a source of inaccuracies
and
even lies then how do we find the truth
i don't regard the media as a source of
as a
source of inaccuracies and lies
they do exist
but by and
large media reporting is
reasonably accurate
uh reporters
the journalists themselves as
in the past do
courageous
honest work
i've
written about this for 50 years my
opinion hasn't changed
but
they do
pick certain things and not other things
their selection there's framing
there's ways of presenting things
uh
all of that
forms a kind of
propaganda system which you have to work
your way through
but it's
rarely a matter of straight outright
lying
so there's a difference between
propaganda and lying of course
a propaganda system
shapes and limits
the material that's presented
it may tell the truth within that
framework
so let me give you a concrete example
which i
wrote about extensively
i have a book called manufacturing
consent jointly with edward hermann
it's about the
his term which i had accepted the
propaganda model of the media
a large part of the book is defense of
the media
defense of the media against
harsh attacks
by freedom house
several volumes they published attacking
the media
charging that the media were so
adversarial and dishonest that they lost
the war in vietnam
well i took the trouble of reading
through the two volumes
one volume is charges the next volume is
evidence turns out that all of the
evidence is lies
they had no evidence
they were just lying
the media in fact were doing the
journalists were doing an honest
courageous work
but
within a certain framework
a framework of assuming that
the american cause was
basically just basically honorable
making mistakes
doing bad things
but all
but the idea of questioning
that the united states was engaged in a
major
war crime
that's off the record
so unfortunately there was this crime
and that crime which
uh
harmed their effort to do good and so on
well that's not lying it's propaganda
so how do we find the truth
how do we find the truth
that's what you have a brain for
it's not deep
it's quite shallow
it's not it's not quantum physics
put a little effort into it
think about
look for other sources
think a little about history
look at the documentary record
it all pretty well falls together you
can get a reasonable
understanding of what's happening
you